make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so in this video on too powerful
for the Marvel movies I want to talk
about the character of null but also
what I do here is I want to clear up
some confusion that people have without
like where no resides with regards to
like the various universes that have
existed and like how he compares to
cosmic entities and different things
like that so in in model comic so those
you guys who haven't been keeping up
with this know the symbiote God was
created by Donnie Cates and Ryan Stegman
right he was basically part of Donnie
Cates initial run on them and what we
ended up learning is is using a
combination of different sources if you
go back and you read the old spider-man
comics and you go read secret Wars there
was just this inky black substance it
was in a jar and Spiderman thought it
was a costume and he put it on and it
ended up bonding itself to him or at
least he touched it it bonded itself to
him and then he went forward with like
an all-black costume now in Deadpool
secret Secret Wars Deadpool was the one
that told him to go check it out you
know saying hey there's like a costume
machine maker or someone that over there
whether or not you consider Deadpool
secret secret war to be in continuity is
really up to you it goes and it just
kind of fluctuates I mean honestly it's
it's whatever you want it to be
it's a Deadpool story so there's really
it's it's whatever you want the
continuity be there but the factory
means they're following that of course
we you know as most of you guys know
Peter Parker cast off the the venom
Samia and then it bonded itself to Eddie
Brock and then because I felt betrayed
by Peter who cast it off um both the the
symbiote and Eddie went forward as venom
the villain and then that led to like
the creation of carnage and so on and so
forth but what ended up happening is is
years later right I mean this was
probably three years ago or so who Brian
Michael Bendis came out and started his
run on guardians of the galaxy and he
had a story called planet of the simians
and what we ended up learning is that
venom is essentially the exception to
the rule now the way this worked is you
have planet full of symbionts in the
simius themselves where basically like
space Knights they would bond themselves
to a host and then they would go forward
and there would be protectors around the
universe now you follow that into Donnie
Cates run and then you get Nova symbiote
god combined with Brian Michael Bendis
is run and you get the whole story of
the symbiote so the way this played out
this is where the confusion resides is
the way this played out is that in the
beginning all you had was null now the
way this works is that when it comes to
universes and multiverses and model
comics every time a universe is
destroyed or every time the multiverse
is destroyed everything resets nobody
really goes forward knowing what
happened before the only exception to
that is really like Galactus who lived
from his universe into the next one the
white phoenix of the crown assuming the
entire multiverse is not destroyed and
then lie
those individuals who survived through
the events of secret Wars so like God
king doom and and like a handful of
others like Reed Richards of the
Fantastic Four and and his son Franklin
Richards and Susan storm and so on and
so forth but that usually does not
happen Secret Wars was the exception to
the rule under normal circumstances a
multiverse ends and then is recreated
presumably all life is recreated in the
same fashion but nobody knows anything
about the universe they came before
right so as a result to that when it
comes to null the only logical
assumption to make is that if he
predates the current universe then it
means that null has always existed in
every single universe
I know basically existed in the space
between the universes formation right so
you end up having a universe destroyed
and there's an amount of time that
passes until the universe is remade
no no resides there he's basically born
in that time period and so when when the
new universe is made and the Celestials
start populating the universe with like
galaxies and solar systems and planets
and stars and so on and so forth then
like the battle ensues between Noah and
the Celestials and there's no reason to
believe that it hasn't happened before
but it's like the Battlestar Galactica
thing all this has happened before
and all of it will happen again with
regards to the way this is kind of
explained at the moment when the
Celestials appeared following Knolls
debut or Noel's creation or
what-have-you however it is that he
manifested because we're never given an
explanation of how it is he comes into
existence but regardless when the
Celestials entered into you know kind of
came into existence in what was
basically this yawning void this massive
expanse of just nothingness where the
universe would eventually come into
existence when the the celestial started
creating everything in the universe then
no started freaking out because they
basically intruded on what he deemed to
be his territory and then started
messing with everything and so what
happened was a massive battle broke out
between the two between null and the
Celestials themselves now know by
himself was not really powerful enough
to destroy a celestial instead what he
did is he he created it was called the
all-black necro sword and then killed a
celestial and then absorbed some of the
cosmic energy of the celestial into the
sword and then went forward and tried to
kill more the result was that he was
ultimately defeated and it is kind of
locked away so to speak and so following
this he ended up creating like symbiotes
more or less you know as a means to kind
of expand his influence across the
universe that led into another conflict
and then he was ultimately just kind of
defeated now the issue with this is and
the reason why I say defeated is because
null cannot actually die right he's an
unkillable being he's he's a primordial
entity he's you know it's like Galactus
right I mean I guess he kind of can die
but the
galactus would live on in terms of null
he can never truly be destroyed he can
just be injured to the point where he
has to retreat and then you'll always
end up coming back now muffle never
really explains why especially when you
look at carriages like the lactis who
can be killed the Living Tribunal which
can be destroyed when because you have
beings that are far more powerful than
null
they can be totally killed and
eradicated but somehow no cannot let's
never really explain it's just kind of
the way things are and so as a result of
that what you ended up learning is that
with all the symbionts and all had
created following his defeat the
symbiotes basically started coalescing
around him and form their own planet
more or less and that's where the planet
of the symbionts comes from and because
they were originally created to be
agents of null and there are basically
bad guys with no real leader with no
basically recovering from his injuries
and just kind of dormant that led to the
the Simmi it's basically developing
their own organizational structure their
own kind of civilization and hierarchy
which is where Brian Michael Bendis as
Planet of assembiy it's picks out that
and so what you're talking about here is
you're talking about a being that
basically existed before all cosmic
entities in the universe right so Clah
for like eternity came into existence
before infinity before eon and and all
you know black mistress death before all
these beings came into existence there
was simply no and so with someone being
being that all being that ancient and
that powerful one of the things to bear
in mind is that while he is unkillable
he's not indestructible and I know it
sounds like it I know it sounds like a
contradiction like if he's unkillable he
would be indestructible no you can
injure him to the point where he has to
like retreat and that's what I say with
the Marvel Cinematic Universe as it
stands now with what we've seen so far
well he would eradicate everybody like
if no was brought in to the MCU like if
he just appeared one day or something
like that yeah he would destroy
everybody in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but the beauty about all this
is that there is a way out like there is
a way for the heroes to essentially win
and that way comes in the form of what's
called the light it's a weird concept
and this was really like really answered
like a QA more than anything bye bye
Donny Cass and Reyn Stegman but if no
kind of originates in the space where
there was nothing well there was no life
of any kind whatsoever where nothing was
created was just this massive expanse of
emptiness then the opposite of that
would be the existence of everything
right like the existence of life and all
that kind of good stuff and that's
really like the weakness of null now
it's really kind of weird it seems like
it says like like the movie signs right
like there are these beings out there
who the other their weaknesses water yet
somehow they're able to walk around on a
planet
seventy percent water and like water
vapour and everything like they should
have just disintegrated on site right
like that's kind of the the thing you
would expect with null that if his
weakness is essentially the light or
existence didn't turn like he would be
destroyed as soon as he showed up like
as soon as he appeared but it doesn't
really work that way when Donnie Cates
in Ryan's segment talked about the light
what they're talking about it's usually
what's essentially life-giving forces
right so like elemental energies
lightening different things like that
the power cosmic which has the ability
to create life that's the kind of thing
their discussion this kind of thing
they're talking about this and that's
why we say you know with with null at
full strength if they were to run upon
and if like Galactus were to run upon
them and use the full totality of the
power cosmic it would probably destroy
null but where you also have those kind
of weaknesses you also have weaknesses
like honor and different things on those
lines really more like happiness and in
so on and so forth I know it sounds kind
of cheesy and it is to a degree but
those are really ways to kind of
overpower in and remove simians from the
equation as opposed to you know just
being cheerful and smiling all the time
so kind of focusing on the real meat and
potatoes up life-giving forces this
would really kind of come down to Doctor
Strange in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
that's what would ultimately come down
to right I mean having somebody like
Captain Falcon show up you know and say
hey man like what's wrong you know why
are you so upset and I try to be his
friend at Falcon we get destroyed he
would be like okay you know what like
you're done and he would eradicate
Falcon the boy it was someone like
Doctor Strange because of the kind of
power he possesses and the magical
energy that he wields all he would have
to do is flip through his book of spells
or go to someplace like like the weather
the the God library or whatever it is
where it's like like knowledge about
every kind of God and being that exists
out there I'm all I would have to do is
travel to a location where you can learn
the weakness of null and then in turn
use that kind of power right because
when it comes to someone like dr.
strange he can tap into things like the
power cosmic and I was hard for him to
do and Galactus has to allow him to but
he can tap into it of his own volition
it doesn't have to be given to him by
Galactus more often than not he uses
magical energies belonging to like the
vishanti or a Sid Iraq or Dormammu or
somebody along those lines but he can't
happen those kind of energy sources but
so long as it's an energy source
powerful enough to create life there
represents the light men like null can
be defeated he can be pushed back now
again he can't really be killed so all
that would come down to is Doctor
Strange essentially using the power he
possesses to push null out of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and to throw him into
some pocket dimension or something like
that where he can never really escape
and that's it the more I think about of
the more I that he actually kind of
could work like
a villain he could work in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it would be pretty
cool but in terms of sheer power like
sheer raw power you would overpower
pretty much everyone
Thor using his lightning could cause an
impact on me that's how it worked in the
comics you know Thor incapacitated him
using his lightning but if anything it
was a facsimile of Noll as opposed to
like Noll himself an absolute power in
full-on 100% rejuvenated form if that's
the version we're talking about like a
facsimile well yeah they probably said a
chance but if we're talking about no
full power showing up in the MCU he
would eradicate everybody for the most
part they would all die Doctor Strange
might be able to save them but even then
there's no real guarantee so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end let me know you guys see
down in the comment section about this
I'm really curious what your thoughts
are if you are new here to comments
explained wish you guys at the sub
button to become part of the robb core
if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]